[Musica]
ad ogni luna piena tornerà il lupo
mannaro non è fantastico se vuoi rompere
la maledizione
dovrai superare tutte le prove a e poi
ovviamente ci sarà la prova finale a
casa ma ora è meglio che inizi il
viaggio perché il tempo sta passando e
la prossima luna piena si avvicina segui
la mappa e ricorda se non verrai lupo
mannaro per sempre rimarrà e quante
saranno le tappe soprattutto dove
dobbiamo andare prima al castello forse
o poi avete sentito qualcosa
ecco
[Musica]
così ve lo ricordate
le cose non stanno andando per il verso
giusto dosaggio della seconda tutto
procede secondo i piani è sicuro
le unità e di là che si sta trasformando
il lupo non una piena sta arrivando
ok mi fido all'inter allora ma sei
sicuro che non ci sia un'altra soluzione
ne sei proprio sicuro ma la miglior cosa
per attirare un lupo se non travestirsi
da cappuccetto rosso
ecco guardate gli manca solo il cestino
e biscotti ma meglio così perché
altrimenti mi sarei mangiati tutti
[Musica]
ok anita lupo mannaro è entrata in casa
adesso dovrebbe incontrare il lupo che
l'ha spenta tutto procede secondo i
piani
che cos'è questo rumore forse è meglio
che vado a controllare
[Musica]
la porta è chiusa lo so si stanno
dicendo euro
peccato che non capisco il cagnesco e
cioè volevo dire il lupesco no sarei
proprio curioso di sapere che cosa si
stanno dicendo
no qui si mette male sta succedendo
qualcosa di sarah ma sembra che stiano
litigando ma potrò davvero fidarmi del
lupo spero proprio di sì qui si mette
male non so se devo intervenire forse è
meglio di no tra due lupi magari esco
fuori sbranato sembra che abbiamo smesso
di litigare
c'è molto silenzio forse è meglio
iniziare ad entrare il piano piano
[Musica]
anita stai per il lupo è scomparso che
la sony con un po viveva al piano di
sopra che cosa è successo mercoledì il
lupo si è sacrificato per te per farti
tornare normale
la maledizione del lupo mannaro esatto
era questo che voleva dire con prova
finale non ci avevamo pensato troppo
veleno dispiace se dovuto sacrificare
per me mancherà tanto
anche a me purtroppo era l'unica
soluzione gli ho chiesto se c'erano
delle altre possibilità per salvarti
mi ha detto di no un nome ti spiace un
sacco
ora non ho più la maledizione del lupo
però non mi terzo numero più o meno
mannavola luna piena
per fortuna siamo riusciti a vincere la
challenge si ma qualcosa mi dice che non
sia finita qui
guarda che cosa c'è qualcosa per terra
cos'è un era una mezza luna ha lasciato
il lupo quando è scomparso cosa vorrà
dire che forse come un talismano che mi
proteggerà dalla maledizione del lupo
mannaro
beh speriamo di sì allora bellissima
grazie per esserti sacrificato per me
ora forse riusciremo a stare più
tranquilli speriamo ma qualcosa mi dice
che abbiamo vinto questa challenge ma
non la battaglia
beh speriamo che ora si lasceranno in
pace verrà più nessuno a disturbarci
forse
[Musica]